welcome back the viva las vegas
rockabilly weekend who is sponsoring
this segment is happening this weekend
at the orleans music cars fashion and
food you're gonna find it all then i
stopped by earlier for a sneak peek
welcome to viva las vegas welcome to the
world's largest rockabilly festival now
the man behind it all this is tom tom
thanks for having us my first question
is what is rockabilly rockabilly
originally was a form of 50s music
which was just before rock and roll with
people like elvis carl perkins joey
lewis people like that but now it's so
much more it's become used as a term for
all types of 50s music and things
associated with that scene i love it and
that's what we're celebrating this
weekend it's a huge festival we're going
to walk here because there's so much
going on happening right now at the
orleans we've got cars we'll get to them
in a second but talk about the music
that's taking place this weekend it's
all 50 style rocking rock and roll
rockabilly rhythm and blues do [ __ ] but
it's
mainly younger bands of today who are
playing the music and you have like
there's like burlesque shows and fashion
shows taking place we've got burlesque
shows there's like six performances of
burlesque bingo there's three
performances of the burles showcase and
the burlesque competition we've got
vendors who are selling everything
connected to the scene everything we do
here has to be connected to
like the late 50s early 60s as far as
the clothing too because i see people
walking around it's open right now see
people walking around that are kind of
that rockabilly look going to them
there's fashion shows and people can buy
rockabilly clothes yes i mean you don't
have to be wearing
50 style clothes to come here but
majority of people do and for a lot of
people this is their time once a year
where they're really dressing up and
they've been buying clothes searching
for clothes all year just for this
weekend and the car show that's
happening this weekend this i mean it's
one of the country's biggest car shows
you have over 500 cars but there is a
stipulation i don't know if you've
noticed we're walking through and
looking at these incredible vehicles
they all have a theme what's the one
stipulation with your cars every car has
to be built before 1964
and it has to be period correct so
because it fits that rockabilly feel
yeah so it's as a car would have been
back then
so if someone goes and spends a fortune
making it look with modern stuff on it
if we can't see it it's okay but
basically the exterior has to look as it
would have done there yeah this one i
mean we see we see we see the rockabilly
the old school look but it definitely
has kind of that modern feel to it you
can tell they restored and modified
these seats it's a gorgeous look to it i
mean look at the uh the octopus skull
shifter i don't think they had that back
in the 50s but it kind of fits the vibe
of the car yeah it does it fits the vibe
of the car and so it's not really really
strict because there's a lot of
expanding on what would have been done
then kind of modernizing it too now the
the car show people come down and see
the cars today but a lot of the cars
will be out on display tomorrow saturday
afternoon saturday's the big day where
we have the most cars we've got the
stage with a load of live bands playing
and
over 100 vendors as well so much going
on here good food and food too yes i'm
gonna have to get my rockabilly shirt to
come out here tomorrow it's been a great
time a great time tom thank you so much
thank you appreciate it thanks a lot
appreciate it
thank you viva las vegas rockabilly
weekend for sponsoring this segment
catch it which actually started today it
runs through sunday at the orleans and
you can walk right up and get tickets or
if you'd like to you can visit viva las
vegas dot net las vegas now we'll be
right